um yeah after he whips my ass he told
the other guy come with my eyes and this
other dude and then he goes yeah you
should be able to take him on that guy
doesn't even have legs and I see this
[__] on Nubs like this look
Let's Go Bart
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode careful boys where Ryan
we are currently
off the Record
feels good to say from over there you
know there's so many other channels now
that use off the Record as their [__]
[__] record isn't there there's one
and then there's segments called off the
Record and there's segments called Hot
Seat how many are called careful boys
with a z zero not many very cool it is
all right I agree oh that's the one Z
this is the Z is that a z
are you doing it like this
yeah
you're z in it yeah I like it like this
right what's that the welcome moose wow
so Bart you recently spent some time
with Tim Kennedy wow American hero good
old America American hero that's so cool
I remember you guys did a live stream
together about uh when all the Asians
are getting beat up yeah all the Asians
getting [__] up yeah and then that was
a cool kind of reaction I feel like
everyone kind of did their own part
during that time to try to make sure
Asian grandmas and everybody weren't
getting [__] up for any fans who might
not know who Tim Kennedy is uh please
yeah who that to me he is like like
Captain America like the closest thing
we have uh mixed with like Jason Bourne
so wow
so what does he do for the military
so he was actually fighting in the UFC
before he even joined the military so
it's just his career and Lifeline is
[__] crazy and I think that's why
like like
um he's such an inspiration of mine
so he was in the UFC and then he joined
the military and then he became Special
Forces Green Beret so it's like cream of
the crop then he becomes a sniper so
he's like super up there and he's one of
the only I think he's the only one that
I've ever heard of that has balance the
two literally
like fighting overseas coming back
fighting in the UFC going back and forth
has been able to balance both oh wow
she's a career fighter and a military
guy and he's well like at a high level
yeah he's made it into the top 10 uh UFC
fighters at middleweight before so he's
a ranked fighter at one point
um and then after he finished like his
uh military stuff I think he's pretty
much done like his career skyrocketed
after that because then he became like
the main go-to guy for History Channel
like whenever they have to like oh like
let's get the guy to talk about Special
Forces or the military or whatever so
did he replace that one General that
used to be the history guy guy Jesse
Ventura not in general though he kept
doing the military history guy on
History Channel I don't know the old
dude okay never mind I only like the
Ancient Aliens crazy doctor guys this
guy he um yeah he's like the like the
main Authority there he's also people
ask him about like um like Crisis in
different countries like he'll like talk
about stuff like there so he has like
actually a lot of different Realms that
he has his own fan base and then now he
started his own like
um kind of like protector course of like
self-defense sheepdog response so he has
like all these things to like help his
whole like ethos about his living is how
can we protect those that we love and so
like everything he does is like just a
different aspect like whether it's
becoming more fit so that you can be a
better protector or actually learning
how to protect or
um like even started at elementary
school in Austin Texas like how can we
develop Future Leaders of America like
that's like he has like 12 companies and
that's a hundred percent of what he's
about and he's like living breathing
that meanwhile he's like just like us
like he's just like a [__] around guy
but you can tell he's a [__] kid
like stuck in a 40 year old man's body
that has the skills of Jason Bourne but
he's literally just like a he's probably
could probably fit in with us he's just
like a [__] around dude you think he'll
do uh shooting games with you where you
guys are holding hands and you have to
shoot when this [__] is whooping
my ass when this [__] was
whooping my ass this fool was like
having sex with me what do you mean
yeah show us like he's like whooping my
ass right and he goes he's like I
[__] love you
[__] bite me so he was being romantic
he was just [__] around like he
[__] bit me and give me goosebumps
and [__]
your back started arching you're like oh
oh oh oh
I would tap but it feels too good
he's just the [__] around her that's
tight yeah he's a [__] around her but
anyways yeah um he was in Vegas because
there was a shot show which is like a
really really big like uh Firearms
Tactical
um like gun convention so he hit me up
and he was like Hey I'm gonna be in town
and then I'm like oh [__] let me see if
I can move some [__] around and uh I
ended up having one day when I got to
shoot with them and another day we did
like a bunch of grappling [__] so is he
a pretty good shot
I mean there's this one video that we
posted that looked like nope he's like
I'm waiting we did this one video we
posted so I'm like decent I think and
then so we were doing like these timer
drills like beeps and then you try to
like get on target within like a second
and a half that's crazy so I'm just
focused on mine he's in his Lane I don't
even know we're [__] competing but
then of course he's a giant kid so like
after about five shots he goes hey just
let you know I'm making sure my second
or third round is hitting before your
first one does I'm like dude
damn don't do it I'll do it again and
I'm like and I would literally
oh my God I was like oh [__] cause and
now I start thinking like macro right
I'm like dude if you're a [__]
terrorist or whatever the [__] on the
other side and you guys like you like
see catch catch eyes
this [__] is putting three
rounds into you before you could even
like
Indiana Jones movie is that are those
oblivions
I'm like that's [__] dope the amount
of training that he has is holy crap you
know you know with our training at the
airsoft field
I feel like in War I would probably be
one of the first ones dead 100
I might beat you to it you think so dude
I'll die quick because I realize there's
like campers and then they're just like
[__] [__] right I don't think I just
[__] it and I just go in so then all
these bullets are hitting there you know
I should probably take this more like
real but it's like when you're too
scared you just don't think and you shut
down and you just go and you probably
know like the airsoft's Not Gonna Hurt
anyways so you're like ah [__] I just
right yeah run up on these Situation's a
little different but yeah the grappling
day was the same kind
the grappling day was really eye-opening
because one of the exercises we did was
we start from the knees in like a
grappling position and then so I have a
gun in my waistband he has a knife in
his waistband and then you touch hands
just like you know any grappling match
goes and uh I think what they wanted to
demonstrate they didn't tell you the
lesson until after so you just go you
just go oh so you you know what you're
armed with you have like a dummy gun
yeah a dummy gun has a dummy knife so as
soon as we touch hands the first thing I
do is I aim for it because like that's
what everyone thinks right all [__] that
guy could [__] me up all I need is a gun
but I pull my gun out humidity goes two
on one on my hand and I'm like it turns
into a jiu jitsu match immediately so
what they're trying to demonstrate and
he ends up shooting me with my own gun
he whipped pistol rips me a bunch of
times he takes his knife out stably 30
times like carotid artery [__] takes
off all my nuts like he just wrote
history in my ass and then what he was
trying to show is uh like what you would
normally do yeah he's like what he's
trying to show is Jiu Jitsu is literally
like in self-defense it's up here if
you're in arm's length do the person you
have to get dominant position first
because people think if I have a gun or
I have a knife or [__] nunchucks or
whatever the [__] that if you're not in
a dominant position the other person
will use it against you and even for me
that who has done the Jiu Jitsu on and
off I didn't even think like that
because that was the first thing I
wanted just go for the gun yeah I was
like oh dude I thought I thought in my
mind I thought it was gonna be like this
in slow motion
I was gonna be able to go like this
boom boom boom
that's what I thought that's what I
would think but it wasn't arm's distance
he immediately took my gun I'm like oh
[__] oh Daddy
what's the real move are you supposed to
go okay
yeah get distance and then shoot yeah
the real move is Jiu Jitsu get in a
dominant position side mount get his
back like get leverage first then use
the word exactly as if the weapons don't
exist do Jiu Jitsu get an under hug good
whatever and then when you have control
of the situation then you pull the
weapon up so after he's unconscious then
gun to the head that's what John Wicked
us yeah wow and then you go the dead has
been paid yeah so I had like a five
minute match with them he just whooped
my ass for five minutes and then after
this [__] is like six his whole
[__] team on me what yeah like well
because like I guess like I'm like the
the YouTube guy so everyone's like his
whole team is like all special forced
navies or whatever everyone's like
salivating oh they're like I want a
piece of this guy yeah yeah everyone and
then when I first met him when I feel
like let's [__] with his dummy when I
first met the team it felt like um you
know the uh what's the show that goes oh
um
Family Matters no that's whole house
yeah yeah it felt like that it was like
hey Bart so that's that guy uh 20 years
and Navy Seals like
credits
you put the jacket over his side so I'm
not like [__] like eight eight
[__] like Jason eight Jason the Full
House of vocal just it's a full house a
Navy Navy yeah I was like I was like
honestly I was like with these seven or
eight fools here I was like you guys
think you could take over like Las Vegas
and then like they would burn this
[__] down
holy [__] oh there's specifically a unit
no no they're all retired guys that came
together to help create this company got
it yeah what the the Sheepdog response
afterwards
um yeah after he whoops my ass he tells
the other guy come [__] whip my ass
and this other dude come [__] whip my
ass and then he goes hey you should be
able to take him on that guy doesn't
even have legs and I see this
[__] on Nubs like this look
let's go apart like that and then I was
like [__] you better watch the
[__] out and then I got my legs oh oh
what's up oh [__] and then this
[__] got me a side mount like
this
and he's [__] hitting me with his
Nubs and [__] would you say that your
life was sideways it's upside down
because that shakes me out of here
I came home like babe
I got my ass whooped by somebody
and then Geo was immediately turned on
all right it's like you got jumped in
dude he's [__] your name is too
easy dude that's so crazy okay yeah so
they're all different Special Forces
guys yeah all different like with the
same goal to like build like better yeah
because all of them are like 20 30 like
20 30 years in they're all done wow one
of them was Hawaiian his name's Jacob
thank you for kicking my ass oh the guy
with a beard yeah that guy looks scary
as [__] that guy is so [__] cool dude
he's like uh he's like all these
Polynesian tattoos from Hawaii cool
um and he spent like 20 years in the
Army and he taught like combatives in
the army
I knew what my ass the most do that's
fun do you miss being a warrior
kind of I missed that kind of training
because I remember like when he told me
what the day was going to be where we're
gonna grapple grab right to eat and go
shoot some guns and do whatever that
sounds like a dream I was like
dude is this [__] recess or yeah
this is your guys's job I'm like this is
[__] cool dude what about military
life we're like you just train train all
the time so that's different like when
it's like I think you I think the
Special Forces guys get to have fun
because they earned it so by that time
you get to choose your weapon and you
get to you're kind of like Untouchable
so like you'll see all these crazy ass
photos like Special Forces guys like in
Afghanistan wearing Chucks yeah or
[__] in like a Mickey Mouse outfit
[__] they just look like GI Joe
because they have long hair like they
have their own dress code like and they
could do whatever they want they get to
have fun they could put lipstick on
[__] terrorists and then blast them
or do whatever you know they can do all
kinds of crazy [__] wow when you're in
regular military you can't everyone's
like by the Numbers everyone takes a gun
out all right everyone's so clear and
then there's like 100 people so it's
like at the like a regular shooting
range you know everyone has to do the
same thing at the same time so you
didn't get to that enjoyment yeah those
guys they've done all that they earned
it they're in a special League they can
literally go like yo you guys want to
[__] jump in a helicopter tomorrow
they can do wow damn dude there's a
story that Tim Kennedy told um Joe Rogan
when I realized I was like oh this
[__] is like the real deal he I
think he was in Iraq or something like
that and he was saying that there was
the village that he was staying in and
there was I guess some some [__]
really bad people through acid on this
little girl
and she was like obviously [__]
destroyed and really [__] up and they
were like all right so next day they
found out who did it they pulled up and
they killed all of them and I was like
what the [__] is this dude like I had no
idea that you could even do that was
that like an order that they got to do
that but I think it's the [__] like
tomorrow you want to go on a helicopter
type of [__] like yeah it's like that
kind of so when you're when you're over
there they have very vague orders but
also very clear at the same time so for
example they'll be like hey you know the
whatever XYZ regime like I want that to
be gone in like two months
and then that's it
oh cool let's brainstorm so do I go oh
[__] okay so I know this leader actually
has a side chick that the main chick
doesn't know about can I blackmail this
chick to assassinate or blackmail you
know so how do I topple it from the
inside out so when the U.S leaves they
think the regime collapsed itself so Tim
Kennedy was a Honeypot that [__] like
that I don't so don't be able to he
seduced the terrorist's girlfriend
they'll organize uh whatever strategy
they need to make that whole thing like
collapse from like the inside out don't
be so funny if there's like a there was
a pretty boy of the group and he's
always the sex spot he's always like
he's like the Bear Jew
I'm not a fighter but I can romance them
so stuff like that they get to have
their own jurisdiction you know they
could be like oh wait so that was the
village leader that we've been trying to
establish relationships with the village
leader really cares about this little
girl so to make sure the village
believer uh Village leader believe that
we have his back we'll get revenge for
you so in a unit like that is is there a
tactical guide that's not on the field
that thinks of these like operations no
they're all I think they're all there
from what I understand so then they're
all that level to like formulate a plan
yeah that's crazy when we had Don on I
asked them like how are these missions
like is it like a general that whatever
it goes it's like usually the general
gives like one big mission set and then
the guys they get together and then
they'll literally put together uh
they're like okay this is the process
we'll gather some Recon we all go out do
our own thing so people are on civilian
clothes oh I'm a journalist oh picture
to show whatever and they gathered all
their they take all their data and then
they come up with a PowerPoint and then
they put their plan together and they
brief each other and then they go and
execute and then wow and then so the
that's where the extreme creativity gets
the comes into play and then and then
how big are the teams and is it always
just one like when you say special
forces are don't they work together like
the Green Berets and then the Navy SEALS
or like whatever so it depends on the
mission oh yeah it depends on the
mission so sometimes if it's like uh if
it's like a direct action Mission like
Osama Bin Laden like when we killed him
that's like so the seals were we only
get we have the spotlight on the seals
because they're the ones SEAL Team Six
comes in with the helicopter they I
think they're supposed to like descend
from top down and flush all the bad guys
out they rehearse they literally
rehearse it like it's a basketball drill
um but I think the helicopter crashed so
um like new plans where they go and they
go they actually went upstairs that's
what we hear about what also occurs at
the same time as a bunch of other
Special Operations so whether Rangers or
Coalition forces from other countries
they're securing like the airspace to
help assist yeah because Osama could
immediately call for help and then five
other helicopters come so you have other
special ops securing the airspace and
everything is based off Intel and the
Intel can be faulty people can lie
because your spies on both sides yeah so
people can be like oh yeah someone's
gonna be in building one but he really
isn't building three so at the same time
the other not as specialized groups but
are still special for us because like
SEAL Team Six is here then there's the
other SEAL Teams and the same thing as
like Delta Forces here and the green
Breeze are here the uh they attacked
building one but the other guys are
attacking building two three four five
six seven so at the same time like eight
buildings are getting ambushed whoa so
it's like that's why there's all these
other guys like maybe this guy from
Australia from France or whatever
they're all attack it's the same Mission
if they have the uh super high value
Target like that wow so yeah Tim does
all that [__] so like when I'm like
eating with them I'm always trying to
like look into his eyes to see like the
Thousand like miles stairs yeah
everybody looks at me I'm just like this
and then I'm like and they're even
stabbing me up I'm like oh this
[__] did this for real yeah yeah
you know like the pressure that I feel
I'm like oh he's punctured [__]
these are vital spots yeah yeah I'm like
yeah literally vital spots like [__]
boom boom boom and then yeah like just
be freaking meditated oh specific areas
into my [__] butthole and [__]
stab your butthole yeah a couple times
I'm sure it was the knife that's true
that was a very round knife oh God come
on it almost felt like a flesh knife
you know in the military there's like
these different rankings and hierarchies
right and these Special Forces Group do
they work more like um like a democracy
or is there actually like a team leader
it's way more democratic the
interesting I think everyone has been
through the ratchet passage so that is
more important than your rank but I
wonder how they establish like so if
everyone has different ideas on how to
execute a mission and then like how they
put it all into a pinata and then it
might just be like informal hierarchy
right it's like everybody's like
formally like in a democratic kind of
situation but maybe they're just like
but we know that [__] is a
gangster so I'm down to listen we also
have positions though so it's like
Ocean's 11 where he's the tech guy he's
the he's Recon so he's Recon even though
like uh whatever research I've done he
has the ultimate say when it comes to
research this guy is the playing guy
like don don is the plain guy so if she
hits the fan we gotta make sure uh prior
like as soon as if if our plan goes
Haywire Priority One is get Don on top
of a [__] Mountain so a satellite
phone works they have Specialties
exactly so everyone has a specialty so
they contribute but then they know when
[__] hits the fan who's the shot caller
for each department that's yeah I just
imagine it being that situation where
five guys are arguing about the plan it
gets all tense and loud and then one guy
turns around
we're not going to do anything
and it's the guy that retired yeah
that's a guy that didn't want to come
back he never talks everyone's like yeah
oh my God he's saying something and he's
got an eye patch
but in in Bart's friend's case they're
all retired and then they're all turning
around with cigars five chairs five
chairs they're all like no we're not
doing any of that no we're not no that's
my role it's just a ripple effect
someone always has to say but that plan
suicide and he goes and that's the one
they'll least expect
you asked Tim Kennedy about that
always gonna happen that way
[Music]